[Rires]
[Musique]
salut bon vous avez compris le titre de
la vidéo ces cinq minimes pour les
génies sur le thème des espions alors
juste avant que la vidéo commence sachez
également que j'ai sorti une vidéo
aujourd'hui sur la chaîne secondaire
c'est une vidéo où loïc nous a suivis en
tournée pendant 24 heures à lille
donc il ya diablo il ya céline âge c'est
assez marrant de voir les derrières
d'une date de spectacle je vous la met
en lien dans la description pour
aujourd'hui je rejoins justement c'est
l'image qui aime bien les énigmes et les
jeux autour des énigmes on en fait
souvent ensemble en live si vous
regardez la chaîne eh bien elle va
énoncer les énigmes avec moi et on va
s'alterner aussi dans les résolutions si
vous aimez en plus les énigmes et les
petits bonbons pour l'esprit j'appelle
ça n'oubliez pas que gens postent
régulièrement en story instagram et en
dehors sur instagram c'est du contenu
supplémentaire
vous pouvez que dis-je vous pouvez si
vous voulez parce que vous êtes libre
une petite phrase des manipulateurs me
suivre sur cet instinct g mais c'est
parti pour les cinq henning pour les
génies sur le thème de l'espionnage
loïc générique pour cette première et
ding je vous présente le tombeau la
stèle la dalle rien à voir avec le fait
d'avoir envie de manger la dame à
l'intérieur de ce tombeau il y à un
homme qui a une histoire très
particulière
une histoire liés à l'espionnage aux
agents secrets portant il n'en était pas
un c'était juste un grand fan de films
d'agent secret de films d'espion et son
décès est lié à ça et voici son histoire
pour protéger son anonymat nous allons
l'appeler jean-claude 007 la veille de
son décès jean claude 007 se fait une
nuit
blanche en regardant des films de james
bond il enchaîne tous les films et il ne
dors pas de la nuit
le lendemain il part au travail donc
sans avoir dormi et à la pause entre
midi et deux il se dit prêt à une petite
sieste jusque là c'est normal
lors de sa sieste il s'endort et rêve
qu'il est lui-même james bond et dans
son rêve
quelqu'un lui tire dessus et au moment
dans son rêve où la balle rentre en
contact avec son coeur il se réveille en
sursaut en train de faire une crise
cardiaque qui lui est fatale il en meurt
instantanément
cette histoire là est complètement
fausse
mais comment on peut avoir la preuve
qu'elle est complètement fausse il y a
un indice quelque chose qui permet de
prouver que cette histoire est fausse
je vous laisse réfléchir quelques
minutes et céline h vous donnera la
réponse
or est-ce qu'on a la réponse je vous
laisse encore quelques petites secondes
est bon je dois vous avez trouvé si
c'est pas le cas
c'était rapide de toute façon ne vous en
faites pas pourquoi on sait que c'est
une fausse histoire que ce n'est pas
réel
et bien parce que rappelez vous on a dit
que il s'est réveillé en faisant une
crise cardiaque
dire qu on de son réveil il était déjà
en train de mourir donc il n'a pas eu le
temps de raconter à qui que ce soit son
rêve
donc on ne sait pas finalement s'il
rêvait de james bond ou d'un dinosaure
ou de lui avec les bras on ne peut pas
savoir à quoi ils rêvaient puisqu'il
était en train de mourir
au moment du réveil on va maintenant
passer à la deuxième énigme et c'est moi
qui vais la faire mais cette fois ci
dans un nouveau décor
est ce que vous seriez capable de
devenir agent secret évidemment quand on
est agent secret on s'imagine bien que
des tas de tests ont été effectués
la montre a été déclassifié est venu le
délivrer figurez vous qu'il ya eu un
tête qui a été fait ici même sur ce pont
alors évidemment quand on fait des tests
l'eba ya plein plein de candidats et des
d'élimination le test que je vais vous
exposer
je vais vous demander de le faire
consciemment pour voir si vous seriez
capable de devenir vous même agent
secret
deux candidats et recruteurs voilà la
dernière question la dernière mission le
jour sur ce pont recruteurs fait appel
aux deux agents pour leur dire voilà
messieurs il yaa code à récupérer ce que
d'être extrêmement apporte vraiment il
pourrait sauver l'humanité absolument si
tout ça n'était pas tarder est bien sûr
je peux pas vous dire où il se trouve
exactement tout ce que je peux vous dire
ce qui se trouve à la bibliothèque
françois mitterrand dans un livre à lire
un livre au milieu des milliers des
dizaines de milliers de livres et la
seule
seul le seul indice que je peux vous
donner c'est que ce code et
retrouvailles entre la page 313 314 du
libre messieurs c'est à vous l'inventeur
là-dessus saute par dessus le jeu mais à
l'âge et grimpe la roche pour ça mais
qui était en moto essence faute
direction bibliothèque françois ngah
mais l'autre très étrangement reste
tranquillement debout et observe le
recruteur avec un petit sourire
évidemment le recruteur et partis
mouvements particulièrement perplexe
l'interroger mais vous vous affolez pas
vous n'y allez pas pourquoi là l'agent
lui répond une phrase seule phrase
et après cette phrase l'euro cote
herbiers ok c'est vous qui êtes engagé
vous êtes notre agent secret qu'elle a
été cette phrase je vous laisse quelques
secondes pour réfléchir qu'elle a été
cette phrase juste après fabien vous
donnera la réponse
[Musique]
parti pour la solution donc de l'énigme
numéro deux alors vous avez bien compris
que c'est à cause des pages de livres il
y avait il y avait une embrouille
quelque part mais c'était pas si évident
à trouver
en fait si on prend un livre n'importe
lequel la page une ce sera toujours
celle ci est donc la page 2 sera
derrière et dans tous les livres du
monde c'est comme ça ce qui fait que si
on bat la page numéro 313 c'est celle ci
et là 314 c'est celle de derrière
en gros ce qu'a compris l'agent secret
c'est que ne pouvait rien à voir entre
la page 314 et 313 puisqu'il s'agit bien
d'une seule et même page
c'est pour ça qu'il est resté parce
qu'ils étaient mal un essai dit ça je
peux y aller pour rien parce qu'en fait
il ya trop de l'embrouillé et c'est ça
qu'il fallait comprendre c'est un test
d'intelligence de vivacité et de deux je
sais pas quoi je vous retrouve dans une
seconde pour la prochaine énigme
vous êtes là vous savez comment je le
sais parce que si vous n'êtes pas là
vous ne m'entendez pas dire vous êtes là
je vais vous raconter maintenant une
énigme sur des meurtres d'agents secrets
vos agents à vous imaginez que vous
arriviez en norvège et vous rentrez dans
un hôtel dans une chambre d'hôtel de cet
hôtel
c'est fermé à clé vous forcez vous
forcez d'arriver à rentrer là vous
retrouver un de vos agents pendu à un
mètre cinquante du sol environ un bon
mètre du sol dirons nous avec une petite
flaque d'eau en dessous oui ce meurtre
est très connue peut-être vous le
connaissez déjà
si c'est le cas ne dit pas comme guy ne
dit pas juste dit pas en fait vous
inspecter la chambre de fond en comble
vous constaté qu'elle était fermée de
l'intérieur que les volets et les
fenêtres étaient fermées donc personne a
pu sortir ou rentrer depuis que votre
agent est décédé encore plus étrange
il n'y a aucun meuble dans cette chambre
il n'y a pas un meuble rien du tout et
votre agent et pendu en plein milieu de
la pièce toujours à un maître un bon
mètre du sol avec une petite flaque sous
lui
donc à un moment donné puisqu'il s'est
pendu comment ça s'est passé pour qu'ils
puissent se pendre parce qu'il n'a pas
pu sauter un mètre de hauteur pour
rentrer dans la corde
bref il ya une embrouille quelque part
que s'est il passé
je vous pose la question vous allez y
réfléchir un petit peu quelques secondes
et céline âge va vous donner la réponse
[Musique]
alors la réponse peut-être que certains
l'ont peut-être que certains ne l'ont
pas comment cet homme qui s'est
malheureusement pendu a pu réussir à le
faire puisqu'il n'y avait rappelons le
aucun meuble rien pas d'entrée possibles
toutes les portes et les fenêtres
étaient fermées l'intérieur malgré tout
la seule chose qu'on a pu constater
c'était une flat le pendu eh bien oui et
bien tout simplement
cet homme a ramené un énorme bloc de
glace qui va permis et une amende de
grimper de se pendre
et on suppose donc que la plaque ce cas
pas ces blocs de glace qui a fondu à
quoi bon mais il ya bien réfléchi on
passe à l'énigme et 4 encore une
histoire de décès d'agents
imaginez vous allez dans l'appartement
d'un de vos collègues et là au milieu du
salon vous le retrouver mort étendu au
sol
il est mort précisément d'une balle dans
la tête dans sa main droite
le revolver qui a servi à le
heureusement à son décès et dans sa main
gauche un dieu dictaphone vous vous
saisissez du vieux dictaphone et vous
appuyez sur le bouton play là sur la
bande
vous entendez clairement la voix de
votre collègue qui dit j'en ai marre
j'en peux plus de cette vue j'en ai
ras-le-bol
je leur charrette et pas vous entendent
également à coudre et plus rien sur la
bande
et pourtant vous le savez de manière
sûre et certaine il ne s'agit pas d'un
suicide mais bel et bien d'un meurtre
pourquoi comment je vous laisse quelques
instants pour y réfléchir et puis je
vous laisse vous retrouvez avec fabien
qui vous donnera la solution certains
états
[Musique]
dans l'énigme que vous annoncez céline
il y avait plein d'éléments différents
dont on sait que l'âme qu'il a dans la
main c'est vraiment l'armé qui a servi à
le tuer on sait également qu'il avait ce
dictaphone et on connaît le message
qu'avait dessus suivi du coup de feu
qu'il l'a tué suivi de rien d'autre
alors comment on peut savoir que c'est
un meurtre la réponse est très simple
quand ces villes à la raconter l'énigme
maladie vous appuyez sur le bouton play
du dictaphone et vous entendez toute la
bande
sauf que pour pouvoir entendre la bande
sur lesdites la fin il fallait que
quelqu'un ait rembobinez le dictaphone
et qui a rang bobines et le dictaphone
assurément pas celui qui est mort parce
qu'une fois qui s'est tiré la balle et
qu'on a entendu pas il pouvait pas dire
et maintenant je rembobine et je me mets
en place non il était mort directement
donc c'est vraiment l'assassin qui a
fait une mise en scène pour faire croire
à un suicide mais qui s'est fait avoir
parce que il a eu comme réflexe de
rembobiner pourquoi on ne s'est pas
tellement pourquoi mais c'est aussi des
énigmes c'est juste d'être créatif et
même si tout est pas toujours logique
dans cette fable prochaine énigmes s'il
vous plaît merci
vous avez découvert les tests d'agents
secrets avec céline âge un mec qui
voulait devenir agent secret et qui est
mort mais en fait on sait aujourd'hui
qu'il n'était pas mort vous avez résolu
des enquêtes d'agents secrets qui était
mort il est temps de passer à la mise en
situation pour cette 5ème énigme c'est
vous qui êtes en mission sur le terrain
vous êtes un endroit particulier mais en
fait on s'en fout royalement de louer
cet endroit vous avez avec vous
seulement deux mèches de dynamite et un
briquet et là il ya votre collègue qui
passent vite fait en courant et qui vous
dit dans 45 minutes exactement
précisément 45 minutes
il faut que tu appuies sur ce bouton
rouge pour annuler une explosion
atomique attendant ce nucléaire
ce show pas se mentir sont plutôt chaud
comme mission le grand problème c'est
que vous n'avez pas de montre il n'ya
pas d'horloge ya rien pour vous donner
le temps la seule chose que vous avez
c'est ces deux mèches de dynamite
vous savez qu'elle brûle entièrement en
60 minutes
il ya une mèche si vous l'allumez elle
mais 60 minutes a brûlé avec une
précision d'horloger mon gars que tu
sais pas et vous avez également un
briquet pour allumer les mèches bon vous
avez compris le but de lening c'est
quand même de savoir comment avec ces
saloperies de mèches va pouvoir calculer
45 minutes
je vous le demande c'est vraiment sale
énigme comment vous pouvez calculer 45
minutes de temps à l'aide de ses deux
mèches et de ce briquet et non pas de ce
briquet je vous laisse réfléchir et dans
quelques secondes à peine
céline âge va vous donner la réponse
[Musique]
alors réponse de cette 4e énigme bon on
verra l est pas si simple surtout en si
peu de temps je vais pas vous mentir ce
port ce pôle est plus facile en tout cas
moi j'ai pas mes préférés il faut
calculer
bon vous l'aurez peut-être compris on va
forcément utilisé est valide de mèche
avec le briquet comment il ya deux
étapes
on va parler de la mèche une à et de la
mèche de comme ça on va résumer de
manière plus plus simple vous aller
allumer la mèche un des deux côtés en
même temps mais à ce moment là vous
deviez vous allez mais également la
messe 2 nous tenons à côté de ça on le
rappelle que d'un côté j'aurai dieu une
mèche allumée des deux côtés la deuxième
est allumée que d'un côté
qu'est ce qui se passe au moment où les
flammes de même une se rejoignent
d'autres tops pour allumer l'autre
extrême que deux mèches 2 pourquoi parce
qu'il se sera écoulé 30 minutes tout
simplement il reste donc à mèche de 30
minutes à s'écouler sauf qu'on vient
justement d'allumer l'autre extrémité de
mèches de dompter deux plats deux mèches
de vont se rejoindre
il se sera écoulé 15 minutes 30 minutes
+ 15 minutes égal
alors je sais pas quel est votre taux de
bonnes réponses ou pas mais j'espère que
ça vous aura plu si vous voulez un petit
peu plus de contenu vidéo n'oubliez pas
qu'il ya aujourd'hui même langue et
reçoit une vidéo qui est sorti sur la
chaîne secondaire c'est hier soir
qu'elle est sorti vous là mais par ici
là vous avez la chaîne de céline âge
n'hésitez pas à découvrir son travail et
à vous abonner à elle c'est drôle c'est
excellent et puis à très bientôt
ciao